a few nights ago almost a million people
showed up to watch
us congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
play among us on twitch her first ever
twitch stream
was the third largest individual stream
in twitch history
look 2020 maybe a dumpster fire
but this [ __ ] was awesome
[Music]
all right so before we go deep on this
massive moment in streaming history
i've gotta remind you scroll down and
subscribe to the channel
when you sub like our videos and comment
it really does help us out
oh if you have a tip for the don't at me
team make sure to hit us up
at tips at thescore.com what became one
of the most significant nights in
streaming history
all started with one tweet alexandria
ocasio-cortez is a us congresswoman
better known by her initials
aoc she's part of a new wave of
politician who
more or less well sometimes get it when
it comes to young people she's extremely
popular among young progressives and on
october 19th when she posted this tweet
asking to play among us to help promote
voting in the upcoming u.s election
well people on the internet were stoked
and some of twitch's biggest names were
clamoring to play with aoc after a night
of setting up
fixing up her stream and run throughs
which i imagine would have been at least
close to as entertaining as the real
stream it actually [ __ ] happened
okay hello hi everyone holy cow
can you guys hear me on this thank you
all so much for
joining my first ever twitch stream
i guess i hope it's not the last at 9 00
pm eastern on october 20th
aoc went live with a full party that
included hassan
pokemane myth dr lupo and disguise toast
during the course of the next few hours
aoc's first twitch
stream peaked at 438
688 concurrent viewers and that makes
her first
ever stream the third biggest individual
stream in twitch history
behind shroud's return to twitch and
that time ninja stream with drake
if you combine the peak of her stream
with hassan's pokemane
and lupos you get well over 700 000
and that's not even including the rest
of the party when all is calculated the
night's total creeps close to
1 million concurrent viewers on twitch
that's a lot of fun
people for a 5 party game now if you're
not aware among us is one of the most
popular games on twitch right now
it's more or less a take on the classic
games werewolf or mafia
it's a deception game where two people
are the impostors and they run around
killing everyone and their identities
are kept secret
and the rest of the party has to figure
out who they are and of course
in their first game together aoc was an
imposter
and was tasked with killing pokemon
don't let me be impossible is there a
way to mute yourself
uh yes i can't kill pokey she's so nice
i can't do that okay i think i have to
do it
yo can we do the thing
it was an honor sorry pokey the party of
twitch streamers naoc was also joined by
illihan omar
another us congresswoman who frankly
schooled everyone in among us prompting
this tweet that rapidly went viral over
the course of aoc's three and a half
hour stream
she did everything from explaining the
importance of voting
to killing her co-streamers to
explaining her stance on health care in
america
so you go to the doctor and then
what happens do you just walk up and you
say i need help
how does that work like i can't even
imagine that interaction without
a credit card or some sort of cash
payment you go to the doctor and you say
i have this problem and then they
prescribe you the medicine and then you
just go pick it up and then you go home
and you google how much it would have
cost in america oh my gosh
the rest of it well as you might expect
when someone famous tries to stream
was chaos hey everyone hey hey your
dreams are live
dwight is that is that weird they just
call you aoc
you guys can call me aoc mike pence
can't call me i aoc but you guys can all
right
okay oh
no this is terrible toast
was with me the whole time but am i
being marinated
is that the term i don't think that is
the thing
i would not marinate a congresswoman
once the dust settled and her stream was
over
as usual everyone ran to twitter to give
their takes on the evening and people
were quick to point out the comparison
of
aoc's numbers to the us army who have
controversially been streaming on twitch
for a while
if you're looking for more information
on that situation we actually did a
video on it
on this show slasher also took the time
to get a nice dunk in on the overwatch
league whose best night of streaming
was eclipsed by aoc's first stream and
that was the end
of one of the biggest nights in the
history of streaming somehow started by
a us congresswoman
a low budget party game and a few big
streamers
which is obviously both hilarious and
awesome
but i think speaks to a larger trend
we've been seeing on twitch over the
last year or so
it sometimes feels weird to say it but
politics
are popular on twitch the internet loves
to argue
they love to take sides and they love to
laugh at stupid [ __ ]
these are all things we know and as this
has become increasingly more clear
more and more people have been looking
to create avenues for political debate
online
like the austin show or literally
commenting on politics as their schtick
like hassan now if you're not aware of
who hassan abby is he's a former
political commentator
turned twitch streamer who now streams
in the just chatting section
talking lefty politics to more than 10
000 viewers every night he also peaked
at around 150
000 viewers a few weeks ago during the
us presidential debate
that [ __ ] is wild sure did last in your
class not at first
the president can you let him finish sir
no he doesn't know how to do that even
maybe the least
serious guy on the internet xqc got in
on streaming the debate
and more than a hundred thousand people
were watching him oh
that's the urban miller aero chair max
all the upgrades he has the arm upgrades
and the armrest upgrades so while i
hesitate to say something cringe like
politics is having a coming out moment
on twitch
there's certainly an avenue for
political content and political circuses
when it comes to streaming now when it
comes to the aoc stream
there were still some haters the usual
crowd of people
in twitch chat yelling boomer every time
she was trying to figure out how her
twitch stream worked
but for the most part i would call it a
w and it's definitely true that the
twitch world made some
headlines the next morning so who knows
maybe if this whole
politics career doesn't work out for aoc
she can start learning how to build
and have a long and healthy career doing
the pon pond dance
and streaming fortnite the reaction like
your little laugh there
as you that was good you liked my life
hey devin yes sir
it's a little too romantic for me i also
want to give a shout out to
[ __ ] everybody in every video that
i've ever done
who thinks i'm high look
i respect i respect the weed smokers i
think it's a fine thing to do in your
free time but believe it or not
i just have really bad allergies and i
don't smoke weed
and i'm not high in the videos i l i
appreciate the the comments though
there's like tons
there's it's every every single video is
the highest highest like ranked comment
i can't believe it man
i swear to god i'm not high i swear to
god